Hello, my name is Tim Brook, and this is my wife, Carrie.
And last year we hosted three
international students for Thanksgiving.
We weren't really sure what to expect at first.
Uh, three of the guys ended up coming.
Um, I was a little hesitant about culture
and language barriers, but, um, that faded pretty quickly.
When we started playing games, we watched football,
we had conversations about their families.
I wanted to know about their siblings, their parents, um,
kind of what they do for fun.
It was fun to share these new experiences
with people for the first time.
Uh, I'm a parent of two college kids
that are away from our home, not too far,
but enough away that, uh, when they're with other families
or in other homes, I'm at peace with that
because I know they get to experience something outside
of their normal in this kind of environment and situation.
We get to pay that forward with their kids who are miles
and miles away from home.
And we get to love on these kids who aren't near family.
So that was really important to us to host these kids
and to have them in our home and to share a meal together.
What my encouragement for others would be
is you really don't know what you're missing until you,
uh, spend time with these internationals.
And, uh, even though it may be intimidating, um,
these are just human beings that, uh, are in most
of the time, um, an environment
that they've not been in much, uh, before in their life.
So, um, they're probably scared or lonely.
Um, and it's an opportunity that we have to share the love
of Christ with them, um, and give them some peace
and comfort, um,
and a place that they are not used to being.
Um, a couple of the boys that were with us, um,
had only been there for a few months, um,
in America for the first time.
Um, and going to Christmas, um,
gives us even more opportunities to weave, um,
gospel conversations into the conversations we have
with the internationals.
If you are considering bringing in an international
student for your holidays, I highly encourage you to do so.
There is something incredibly special about saying yes
to the Lord without knowing
or, um, having an idea of
what the other side of that will look like.
But when we did that, it, it brought a whole new level
of just how close God is to us in those moments,
and how precious those times are when we open up our homes
and ourselves to people that are not like us.
You know, if you're considering it all,
just go take the step.